the launch of the RTX 50 Series has been
plagued by underwhelming performance low
stock and black screening drivers and to
top it off Nvidia is embroiled in yet
another Power connector Scandal on their
Flagship RTX 590 Founders Edition at
this point I wouldn't even blame them
for saying you know what screw it let's
not even make a 5070 TI Founders Edition
what they didn't make one nope Nvidia
has left their most a aable 50 Series
yet in the hands of their board Partners
who did their best with it but if you
guys were hoping that the 50 Series
story would get better as we made our
way down to the cards that more folks
can afford well I've got news for you
the good news is that the 570 TI is a
significantly more compelling product
than the 580 but that assumes that
anyone can get it at MSRP and that's the
bad news no one's going to be getting it
at MSR RP but you know what you will get
at MSRP is this segue to our sponsor HRS
increase visibility to your website with
HR is free to use SEO tools you'll get
access to their SEO health tracker an
up-to-date list of search friendly
keywords and more just by clicking the
link in the video
description the 570 TI sits in kind of a
weird place it arguably has the chops
for 4K gaming but in our opinion The
Sweet Spot for it is high refresh rate
1440p gaming or very high refresh rate
like Esports 1080p gaming let's start
with the ladder in Allen wake the 570 TI
manages a 9% uplift over the 470 TI
super but then loses to amd's aging 7900
XT in f124 the 570 TI inches a bit
closer to pull position and gets closer
still in sci-fi Rog like Eternal in our
Vulcan test Red Dead Redemption 2 we see
the 570 TI finally surpass the 7900 XT
but it's not until we look at cyberpunk
where we see a result that meets the
technical definition of a lead albeit
barely with that said thanks to its much
better one% lows the 570 TI tops our
charts in The Last of Us Part One and
properly beats team red in black myth
Wukong across our suite of games then we
see the 570 TI pull off a serviceable
15% lead over its last gen counterpart
but we also see it demonstrate clearly
why Nvidia wishes that everyone would
just forget that that card was replaced
by a more Super variant just over a year
ago it surpasses that card by only 9% B
of course at 108p it's easy for a card
this powerful to end up CPU bottleneck
so let's push some more pixels to get a
better idea of where the 570 TI sits in
the product stack right out of the gate
it manages a measurably better
improvement over the last gen super at
1440p and what a 10% is a measurably
more than
nine but even then it still fails to
break away from Team Red's 7900 sandwich
which further illustrates just how
disappointing this generation is for
gamers typically we would expect a new
70 class GPU to beat or at least match
the last Generations 80 series but now
not even the 70 TI can stand up to the
last gen 80 card
that kind of sucks unless you have a
4080 in which case hey Nvidia just saved
you a lot of money maybe it makes up for
it in ra tracing though and well hey it
Compares much more favorably to AMD here
whose 7,000 series RT capabilities are
more like two generations behind Nvidia
but we are still looking at a me uplift
over the 470 TI super I mean if you want
to crank the I candy without upscaling
at 1080 the 57 ETI delivers a great
gaming experience outside of the
notoriously demanding black myth Wukong
but 1080p Ultra used to cost like 300
bucks not 750 bucks the good news is
that 1440p Ray tracing puts the 570 TI
in its biggest lead over last gen so far
a
133% so if you pretend that the super
doesn't exist the 570 TI does provide
decent generational uplift but the nons
super that Nvidia wants us to compare it
to was mocked for its dismal value
proposition and given that I have supers
in my warehouse right now it's clear
that nvidia's Operation Kronos failed
superly so why isn't nvidia's new 50
Series Blackwell much better well for a
couple of reasons but the main one is
that it's manufactured on the same 4N
process note as it's pred processor and
makes relatively light changes to the
underlying architecture compared to last
gen we get lightly improved Ray tracing
or RT cores moderately improved tensor
cores for AI and this one is key
seemingly unimproved Cuda cores which do
the bulk of the work in traditional
rendering the main step forward seems to
be better integration between the AI and
the rendering course for the sake of
future neural rendering technology that
demos admittedly very well right now but
it's going to take time to see
widespread adoption in games you can
play with all of that said Blackwell
cards do get some pretty big
improvements that don't show up on the
FPS charts the media engine for encoding
and streaming is capable of
significantly higher quality DP 2.1 uh2
connectors at the back allow these
monsters to drive 4K displays at up to
240 HZ without compression and the jump
to gddr 7 memory means that our vram is
now one greater than six but oh no it
must have heard me say neural rendering
hide DS S4 with multiframe Gen is coming
and it's coming in hot I'm talking over
150 frames per second in cyberpunk at 4K
with raay tracing set to ultra dang and
we get improved image quality over
previous generations of dlss our frames
look closer to Native rendering thanks
to the new Transformer based AI
upscaling model and the new tensor cores
can generate as many as three AI
generated frames for every truly
rendered frame leaving less AI endowed
last gen cards in the dust too bad it
comes with numerous downsides like
lowering your base frame rate only
really feeling good when that base frame
rate is already high enough to be
playable and introducing weird anomalies
like any tool it does have its uses but
don't imagine that it's a magic fix no
matter how much Nvidia wants you to
believe that it is of course that
doesn't mean the 570 TI is a slow card
for funsies we got the good folks in the
lab wearing their super awesome LTT Labs
merch from LTT store.com to drag race
the 5070 TI in 4k against its bigger
brother the RTX 580 resulting in
probably the best argument for this card
that we've seen yet obviously it's
slower it's a lower-end card but the
value is much better against a card that
is sold out everywhere and it's got the
same 16 gigs of vram making both cards
likely to be similarly
future
probable I don't want to say proof our
Asus Prime card features a triple fan
cooler that uses a flowthrough design
it's a little thicker than two slots but
it isn't any wider or taller than the
580f and managed to keep this 300 watt
card at around 70° in both f124 and in
combuster in our power tests while we
did see a transient Spike as high as 360
WTS overall the seems well behaved as it
pulls roughly 9% more power than the 470
TI to deliver your sweet sweet FPS for
power delivery Asus uses the scandalous
connector that's been making headlines
for melting on Founders Edition 509s but
the lower power draw here by half means
that melting cables
shouldn't be an issue uh on an unrelated
note when's the last time you checked
your smoke alarm the 570 TI is clearly a
gaming focused product but we like to
take a look at productivity anyway and
we were unsurprised to find that the
biggest generational uplift is in you
guessed it AI with most of our
benchmarks seeing substantial
improvements over last gen and
especially over the competition from AMD
while the models that you can run will
be limited by your mere 16 gigs of vram
you're no more limited than you would be
on a
80 cool card that one as for 3D modeling
don't expect much of an improvement and
for video editing the new card proves
capable if not Sensational with very
similar performance to the 580 just note
though that the 70 TI has one fewer
decoda engine compared to its bigger
brother so for a very large multi-cam
setup for instance you could overburden
it and end up putting additional strain
on your CPU all right with that out of
the way what's the conclusion for this
thing well it's complicated if you spent
$599 for a 2070 super way back in the
day you might be happy to spend 150
bucks more than you did last time on a
570 that Nets you over 2 and 1 half
times the performance and that that's a
totally valid perspective so why are
reviewers so pissed off about this thing
and the 50 Series in general well it's
because at one point you could wait that
same 6 years and the card that you
upgraded to would be over three times as
good for essentially the same nominal
price and then if you factored in
inflation it would technically be
cheaper not to mention that these new
cards here can't even be bought at those
advertised prices for reasons that seem
to mostly come down to Nvidia
prioritizing their AI customers and
their shareholders over Gamers so yeah
I'm mad because For the first time in my
lifetime the trend of more powerful
Hardware being available to more people
driving a boom in access to information
and Economic Opportunity that Trend
seems to be going in reverse maybe amd's
radon team can save us yeah I don't know
if I'm hopeful but I'm hoping hoping to
tell you about our sponsor rocket money
no one likes hidden fees but sometimes
they're kind of hard to Snuff out
however what's worse is when you get
charged for a subscription service that
you forgot to cancel earlier in the year
I mean that's on you but doesn't have to
be for long rocket money can help round
up all of your subscriptions into one
easy to look at list and it even lets
you cancel the ones you don't want with
just a few Taps all directly through
their app think of all the money you can
save but wait now what do you do with it
well rocket money can help with that too
their budgeting feature can analyze your
spending habits and send you alerts when
you're being just a little too wild with
your purchases and for those bills that
you do want to keep you can upload
pictures of them to the app and a
representative from their team can
negotiate on your behalf to try to get
you a better deal so don't wait go to
Rocket money.com LT or click on the link
in the video description to get started
for free if you guys enjoyed this video
why not check out our 90 review
obviously that's not a card most people
can afford but it goes into a little bit
more detail about the Blackwell
architecture and all the benefits it has
over last gen